it was that I heard maybe a couple years
ago that you and Katt Williams went or
had an investment or something together
I don't was a restaurant no I want to
say what a burger or something but I'm
not sure whenever asked me to invest the
restaurant was Nick Lachey
really he opened the bar Lachey's and he
he tried to get any opened the bar in
the restaurant but he was trying to get
all like Cincinnati investors mmm so we
got like a couple couple the Reds and
the Bengals and other people in there
and it just when I talk to my accountant
he was just like restaurants aren't a
good investment not doing that yeah yeah
you don't want to put up any that amount
of money for that
but you're doing so you and Katt
Williams never did like a water burger
and it's like man I know where you hear
that have you ever worked with Katt
Williams or met him yeah we yeah every
black comic I know trust worked I've
worked with every one of them Wow what
does Katt Williams like because I saw
him one time right he was riding on a
bicycle with that at those uh it had
like these kind of lights in the wheels
down Sunset Boulevard with a couple of
other guys oh really
yeah cats he reminds me of a kid kind of
he marches to the beat of his own drum
without question like you know he got
realized I've known Casas ninety-eight
Wow so that's when he first had one
tooth in the front you know and then but
he was it was crazy cat always rolled
like he was a huge star even when he was
like featuring he had a bodyguard Wow
even when he got on JetBlue he had a
bunch of fake chains on like he was
rolling like I'm the guy just waiting
for it yeah and then when he got Friday
the the second Friday it was like that
part was written for him but nobody else
can play that yeah you know I mean other
people could but it was him it was all
him you know what I mean so he always
rolled again he didn't with it and I
I've said this on stage he did one of
the coolest things a comic ever did for
me after a show and I we were in Austin
Texas and it literally was a - it might
be one other person was me and cat on
the show and it was a weird time in his
career because six months prior we had
at Kent State and he was bubbling like
people knew him but kind of knew him
right and then all sudden I got this
contract and we were at the
basketball Rena were the University of
Texas plays I go why would we be there
I'm thinking me and cat are good for
like 1500 seats right not 10,000 right
and I get there and I go oh [ __ ] this
guy popped in six months right Wow so is
that pretty crazy to see what was it
like to kind of witness something like
that
just like it happened I don't really
think about my I don't think it could
have happened it was it the first time
you kind of saw something like that
happen yeah I was like you're more like
how like what what was it that made him
pop because I think we're every now that
it happens like what tiffany has and
girls trip there's that one role that
people just boom yeah but I think it's
more now you just pepper people you keep
peppering them and then hope then thing
you taste like yeah yeah right
but I don't know I you know he Friday
had been out for a couple years and then
the HBO special came out and whatever he
just popped and it was crazy so we we
get them with the show and then my limo
we had two separate limousines so my
buddies were in town and I was like I
asked my driver said yo can I get the
limo for a couple more hours he's like
300 bucks and I was like all right so I
tried to give him cash and he wouldn't
take it he goes I need a credit card and
I go put it it's cashing got tell about
you just take it he's dude I can't
company policy as I'm having the
discussion cap pulled up and he goes hey
girl what's going on you going out what
are you doing I see I'm going over
couple hours I said my driver said he
don't take cash needs a credit card and
cackles hold on he took my driver round
the back of his limo and to this day I
don't know how much money he gave my
driver all the nose cat walked by me and
this is always said he goes he's yours
for the evening Gary enjoy your night oh
yes they do accept cash he just left
no an thanks I had never had service
like this in my life that dude I think
he pulled in the club the club we were
in it that's all I know I mean and then
the guy was there the next why when I
got back to the room with the bed woke
up he was still staying by the car how
much [ __ ] money can't give this guy
but it was just cool like that
but I heard cat was notorious for like
$100 handshakes yeah like he'd tip
somebody to just be a hundred in their
hand
yeah he didn't love that lifestyle loves
to be able to help out he loves to be
able to it's just something like he's a
pimp
he really is yeah but you don't know you
don't know what cat you're getting
something yeah I've personally I'd never
seen the wild bad cat
oh it could be yeah it could be an alley
cat could be a noun can be a house cat
could be a saber-toothed time yeah you
know he's out in that day I've never
I've never had any any real issues that
any comics like not as far as confront
me or what about trap house stuff cuz I
know you know they have a lot of black
Trap House activity have you ever been
involved in anything no dams I'm fresh
prints black man I think the wire man
leaving here a lot of comics hustle
merch
I also coke wrong this is my [ __ ] let's
do tell me everything you know man
I don't know about levar ball okay wow
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one